foreign
Giovanni's up next in Denver Giovanni
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you how are you doing today we're
doing great how can we help
great so I just uh made a horrible
financial decision I leased a car and
now I'm uh 17 000 in debt and um I'm a
full-time student
um thankfully I'm on Full Ride
scholarship they pay for food uh housing
and books everything nice um I worked
three jobs
um I'm a videographer and editor and an
assistant producer awesome what's your
income doing all that
um well it really depends on me and how
many hours I work but usually it's just
around uh what two thousand a month okay
and that's like if you're busting it or
is that just an average if you're doing
your normal thing that's just if I'm
just doing my normal thing okay what's
the payment on the lease
it's uh 300 and then insurance is like
around 400 yippies ouch so you're 700
bucks a month is an expense and you're
making two on a on a decent month
yeah all right do you have any other
expenses any other debt
uh no no I don't have any college debt
or I have a hundred dollars in debt of a
credit card but uh okay well A1 is just
let's pay that off let's cut up the
cards and say no more we're using
Giovanni's money and not the banks
okay so that's an easy start that's a
quick win you can do as soon as you're
off this call and I want you to remember
the pain of this moment Giovanni
I want you to remember how you feel
right now which is like dude I just
screwed myself big time
because this moment right here is what's
going to make you not go back into debt
hopefully ever again right
yeah for sure all right so we're going
to get ourselves out of this thing and
there is a way to do it depending on the
terms that you signed do you know what
the car is worth
uh yeah on Kelly Blue Book it's like
worth what eight thousand nine thousand
it's only worth eight thousand seventeen
uh yeah it's a 2000 so I I at least a
used car
how much do you how much do you owe like
what's on the lease
oh uh so it's I bought it for 11 000 and
then there's this finance charge of five
thousand okay you had mentioned 17
earlier
well 13. got it yeah oh shoot all right
have you found out the early buyout
amount from the the lender
uh no I haven't called about that yet
okay that would be your next piece of
homework to find out is what it would
cost to buy yourself out of this lease
and then based on what the car is
actually worth that gives you a kind of
number to go all right
either I'm underwater on this thing in
which case it would be the only time we
would tell you hey go down to your local
credit union and get a small loan to
cover the difference so that you're able
to pay that car off and now at least we
have a you know a four thousand dollar
loan instead of a 11 000 loan
so that's how it works would I just uh
sell the car first and use that money or
get the title in my hands first you're
gonna need the title in hand but you
can't do that until you won't have a
clean title until the car is paid off so
you need to pay it off first to have the
title to then sell it
um and you're going to need to get a
probably a small loan to do this if
you're underwater it sounds like he
might need a decent like depending on
what it's worth if it's only if it's
truly only worth eight thousand which
still feels super low it does is it
because of the used car market slowing
down
I'm not sure it's uh that's what I got
on on Kelly Blue Book that I was pretty
disappointed it's a 2011 uh
Mercedes-Benz C-Class I bought it
because I thought it would get me more
clients
um make me feel more established it was
a stupid decision I've never once worked
with a videographer because they drove a
Mercedes I work with them because their
work was excellent facts yes yes which I
know you know that now yeah but just for
anyone listening out there who's like
whoa if I get a Mercedes more people
want to work with me because I think I'm
really successful that's what they do on
real estate
well those people are divas yeah
okay so Giovanni you got your homework
ahead of you man but this is a this is
one of those stupid tax situations where
you go remember when I was a knucklehead
at 18 and I made that stupid decision
never leasing a car again Gonna Save up
and pay cash for that used car and uh to
get myself out of the situation that's
right and a key point that George made
is you know after because you are gonna
have to pay some stupid tax on this I
you know hopefully it's not 8 000
hopefully it's worth a bit more but if
you end up getting a loan to cover the
difference yeah you know a six thousand
dollar loan is better than being 17 000
in debt but the key is the money that
you gain from the sell of the car that
is your car budget that's what you're
spending on the next car and you're
paying for it cash and then you got to
pay whatever dead off you know from from
getting out of that lease and and I
gotta for anybody listening
when it comes to car leases you know you
you hear us say all the time I mean Dave
used to say it's not a car lease it's a
car fleece right because it you're
getting screwed you're getting screwed
every way that a that this thing can get
you and I think a lot of people don't
realize this because I'll be honest you
know back in the day Giovanni I thought
that car leases were for rich people I
thought that that was the way like if
you want to show your status you get a
car lease boy was I wrong I was so wrong
because they get they get you four ways
if you don't if you're out here
listening and you don't understand this
car leases get you four ways number one
you know he's got to use the lease but
most people use lease a brand new car
right and a lot of us don't realize this
but the cost of that goes down 60 to 70
percent in the first four years so they
build that in then they add in interest
which they call cost of capital and then
they add in you know their own profit
and then wear and tear you're getting
screwed people gross well Giovanni keep
working your tail off on those side gigs
to get as much income as you come sock
away that cash that you can get a beater
car once that lease is out of your hair